[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue ravi de vous retrouver pour notre
rendez vous quotidien avec quatre sujets
dont vous allez voir qu'ils sont assez
différents en espérant qu'ils seront
tous aussi intéressants
on reparlera des gilets jaunes
l'intervention présidentielle d'hier n'a
pas suffi pour calmer les ardeurs du
mouvement puisqu'il y aura une nouvelle
manifestation samedi
alors on se posera la question macron
at-il tout faux on s'intéressera aussi
aux tensions de plus en plus vive entre
la russie et l'ukraine
la marine russe a résonné trois navires
militaires ukrainien c'était dimanche
dernier le président de l'ukraine parle
maintenant de la menace d'une guerre
totale faut-il s'inquiéter
craignez-vous une guerre vous nous
donnerez votre point de vue nous
parlerons aussi de l'union des droites
le bleu l'événement bardon est passée un
peu inaperçue mais marion maréchal était
lundi soir dans une brasserie parisienne
pour parler de cette nécessaire alliance
entre les électeurs peut-être pas entre
les parties mais en tout cas entre les
électeurs des républicains et du
rassemblement national
est-ce possible on se posera la question
et puis nous intéresserons à la fessée
puisque c'est demain qu'une proposition
de loi pour interdire la fessée passera
à l'assemblée nationale ce sera
l'occasion de vous poser la question
êtes vous pour ou contre cette
interdiction
bonsoir julia de funès ravis de vous
accueillir vous êtes philosophe
spécialiste des ressources humaines du
management vous avez créé un cabinet
s'appelle profil conseille et vous êtes
aussi le co auteur avec nicolas bouzou
de la comédie inhumaine c'est aux
éditions d'observatoire c'est paru il ya
quelques mois c'est un très grand succès
de librairie jérôme sainte-marie bonsoir
vous êtes politologues sondeurs
président de la société pôle inbox votre
dernier livre le nouvel ordre
démocratique a été publié aux éditions
du moment
bonsoir maxime des gayets qu'elle soit
êtes expert associé à la fondation jean
jaurès est aussi conseiller régional
socialiste d'île de france
votre dernier livre la grande des
possessions pour une éthique numérique
européenne a été publiée par la
fondation jean jaurès cette année et
renaud girard est là aussi bon soit
renault vous êtes le chroniqueur
international du figaro on retrouve aux
analyses
chaque mardi matin dans le figaro
quotidien votre dernier ouvrage qu'elle
diplomatie pour la france
prendre les réalités telles qu'elles
sont a été publié aux éditions du cerf
on continue donc avec ce feuilleton dont
on ne se lasse pas celui des gilets
jaunes
emmanuel macron hier matin a donné le
sentiment de vouloir ouvrir le débat à
la fois en appelant au dialogue avec les
gilet jaune et aussi en expliquant qu'il
fallait avoir une nouvelle approche de
l'écologie peut-être moins punitive
c'était un bien beau discours comme
souvent en voici un petit extrait et
c'est cela au fond la crainte exprimée
par nombre de nos concitoyens ces
derniers jours être laissés pour compte
payer la transition énergétique sans en
bénéficier et cette crainte
je ne peux que la comprendre je ne peux
que la partager tout sera donc mis en
oeuvre pour accompagner socialement
cette transition pour que l'écologie à
la française que nous sommes en train de
faire oeuvre advenir puisse être une
écologie populaire voit le président a
donc annoncé un grand débat dans les
régions qui devraient durer trois mois
il a aussi proposé une nouvelle
fiscalité avec une taxe flottante sur
les carburants on n'a pas exactement
compris comment ça pouvait se passer
mais ça va être concrétisées et puis il
a donc appelé le gouvernement à
rencontrer les gilet jaune et ça s'est
passé hier soir une première rencontre
entre deux porte parole du mouvement et
le ministre de la transition écologique
françois de jure de rugy sauf que en
sortant de la réunion
les gilet jaune n'était pas à calmer et
ils ont même annoncé que la
manifestation
ça recommence et samedi prochains
écouter samedi prochain du coup est
maintenu et ça sera il y aura le
rendez-vous comme samedi dernier aux
champs elysées
en fait les en fait le souhait de tous
les gels et jaune c'est de continuer
chaque samedi comme ça aux champs
elysées maxime de gagner c'était un coup
pour rien on a pourtant eu le sentiment
que le président la république tendez la
main au gilet jaune
c'est un coup pour rien oui parce qu'il
était hors sujet emmanuel macron nous
avait habitués ou en même temps et là
ils n'arrivent pas à faire comprendre
que on peut faire la transition
écologique sans le faire au détriment du
pouvoir d'achat et sur le pouvoir
d'achat les impôts pour faire court sans
alerter ses impôts
certainement mais parce que je crois que
le vrai problème en réalité et ce qui
fait que sa parole est inaudible
aujourd'hui c'est que les gens veulent
de l'équité et ils ont le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui certains payent et
d'autre de toute façon ne payerons pas
et je crois que il faut qu'ils puissent
revenir sur les arbitrages fiscaux du
début du quinquennat notamment la
question du sf qui ait une dimension
symbolique et une dimension réelle c'est
5 milliards d'euros par an et tant qu'il
n'aura pas fait un geste d'équité
je crois que je crains que il ne pourra
pas répondre à la hauteur des attentes
du mouvement de gilet jaune sur sept
maris vous étiez sans gilet jaune mais
vous étiez sur les champs-elysées samedi
dernier pour prendre le pouls du
mouvement vous croyez que c'est ça que
que ces manifestants ils demandent aussi
le rétablissement de la lcf ou bien ils
veulent juste con qu'on baisse les taxes
sur les carburants
alors faut distinguer plusieurs choses
d'une part quand vous êtes sur les
champs-elysées à paris vous êtes
précisément à paris c'est très bête mais
effectivement vous n'avez pas la
population qui est sur les ronds-points
et par ailleurs il y avait aussi une
autre source d'information qui est
également les sondages sur non pas les
participants mais sur les soutiens
qu'ils sont massifs comme un dernier
sondage pour le figaro l'a montré là
dessus donc ce que l'on a lorsque l'on
voit clairement c'est la question du
pouvoir d'achat qui est avant tout qui
au début cette attaque dans le carburant
mais c'est une question du pouvoir
d'achat et on voit bien ce que veut
faire le gouvernement d'une part comme
toujours comme tout gouvernement ces
questions-là parler de la méthode alors
on va faire la concertation faire diar
concertation c'est à dire qu'on ne va
pas changer d'avis précisément qu'il ya
une concertation s'il ya un grand débat
sur trois mois pourquoi pas sont trois
ans et bien évidemment c'est parce que
les décisions sont prises et seront
appliquées
donc en réalité la concertation c'est
par définition
alors ça plaît beaucoup notamment une
certaine 2
gauche et c'est traditionnellement mais
en réalité on sait la cfdt appelaient à
cette station ne me sentais pas donc
c'est une fin de ce fait une fin de non
recevoir
et par ailleurs il ya aussi un autre
problème beaucoup plus sérieux c'est que
il ya ils essayent de détourner le
problème sur la question arbitrage
écologie pouvoir d'achat or la taxe sur
le carburant n'est pas en termes logique
et ça l'opinion l'a compris une
incitation à plus d'écologie puisque
c'est une taxe précisément sur
l'utilisation d'un véhicule que l'on est
contraint d'utiliser pour la part des
français
ça serait une taxe par exemple sur tel
ou tel type de véhicule pour inciter les
gens à choisir un véhicule moins
polluant je crois que ça existe
d'ailleurs cela au effectivement on
aurait bien un raisonnement sur la
transition écologique mais c'est une
taxe qui est destiné simplement à faire
rentrer davantage d'argent pour l'état y
compris pour compenser une fiscalité qui
a été comment dirais-je modifié et bien
à ce moment là pour l'instant photos
volées les éléments soutien des gelées
jaune alléger les jeunes eux-mêmes ont
bien compris et restent radicalement sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat
vous citiez un sondage effectivement
vous faisait allusion au sondage
opinionway qui a été publié dans le
figaro de ce matin et qui nous montre
que 76% des personnes interrogées
considèrent que les mesures annoncées
hier par emmanuel macron ne sont pas
suffisantes pour répondre aux
revendications des gilet jaune
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ont
posé la question hier aussi sur le site
du figaro enlacé par un sondage que sont
les internautes qui répondent alors
c'était encore plus accentuée il y avait
85 % de gens qui considérait que ces
mesures n'étaient pas suffisantes
ce qui est intéressant c'est le nombre
de votants presque 90 milles et c'est
beaucoup pour une pour une
pour le figaro.fr renaud girard avez
vous envie de défendre le président de
la république
oui je suis évidemment il était le mois
dernier en appétit avant donc je ne
savais pas quoi la voilà voilà je vais
le je vais le défendre
sur ces deux points je pense qu'il a eu
tout à fait raison d'abord d'abolir lisf
kita des impôts les plus imbéciles qui
est créé qui est écrire en france qui
était créé par les socialistes s'étaient
c'est pas un impôt qui sert à ramener de
l'argent c'est un impôt de vengeance
sociale c'est à dire on va taper ont
fait payer les riches on tape les riches
parce qu'ils sont riches qu'ils ont
réussi c'est un impôt qui a été refusé
et par tous les pays d'europe y compris
des pays qui avaient des gouvernements
socialistes eux-mêmes aboli cet impôt
sur la fortune parce qu'on peut et déjà
un impôt sur le revenu on paie déjà
quand on veut transmettre de l'argent à
ses enfants un atout sur l'héritage
avoir un impôt sur la fortune qui peut
d'ailleurs allé assez haut parce que
sous le camarade hollande il était de 1
8% alors que les taux bancaires ne vous
donnerai pas lorsque vous passez de
l'argent à la bnp 1,8 pour cent
donc c'était un impôt confiscatoire et
surtout cet impôt qui dans une europe où
les frontières sont ouvertes ça
simplement fait fuir
c'est pour ça c'est pour les faire fuir
les investisseurs il faut évidemment
quand on a les socialistes ont ouvert
les frontières
ben quand on est il faut garder les
investisseurs chez nous et voilà c'est
sur le diesel et sur l'essence alors
peut-être que effectivement les
carburants sont trop taxés en france
d'une taxe à peu près de 360% je parle
sous le contrôle de monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
de la région ile de france
je crois que c'est 160 % mais mais alors
est-ce que voilà c'est dans la moyenne
européenne et moi je personnellement je
n'ai rien trouvé à redire à cette taxe
mais ce que je comprends schéma congio
crise a eu raison de pénaliser le diesel
par rapport à l'essence est ce que le
diesel alors c'est pas de sa faute si on
a fait une politique tout diesel qui est
une grave erreur là on peut le dire d'un
banc de la droite qui s'est mis dans le
diesel à fond ensuite de la gauche qui a
continué le diesel à une pollution de 16
fois en particules en particules fines
dans les faits et dans les villes c'est
tout simplement une catastrophe des
pauvres qui roulent beaucoup s'ils se
sont acheté un diesel est ce que c'est
normal ce soit eux qui paient alors
ouais alors peut-être qu'il faut
effectivement aménagé
mais les taxes mais le principe est bon
la troisième chose que je veux dire
c'est qu'en fait c'est difficile de
président de la république et je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de politique si vous
voulez qu'ils ne puissent pas sûr qu'il
puisse pas se faire à long terme on peut
pas avoir moi je suis pour la démocratie
c'est à dire que on a on a voté mac os x
le peuple phocéen nouveau débat cruz n'a
pas suivi le figaro le figaro lui avait
dit il faut élire françois fillon et il
a voté mac os mais maintenant il est élu
laissez-les on a laissé non laissons le
gouverner moi je suis pour les décisions
de long terme je pense qu'en 74 on a
fait une prime d'émission de long terme
qui est épatant pour le nucléaire
on a eu bien raison
madame merkel était pris une décision
politique a déjà prévenu démagogique
démagogie pro pour gagner une élection
dans une région elle va elle va le
regretter
je suis tombé et est ce que je regrette
ce que je regrette c'est qu'on est
socialiste
au diable ceux des gay parce qu'il est
membre du parti si ils avaient compris
qu'ils avaient fait quelque chose il
avait quelque chose de très bien qui
était cette éco taxe sur les camions et
bien sous prétexte que quelques camions
qui ont manifesté on l'a on a compris
chez renault la parole
le dernier mot doit paraissent le talent
de l'état le web conserver voilà et
c'est peut-être l'énarque qui paie qui
parle je ne sais pas mais je ne sais pas
m'en tombent et à ses citoyens pour le
citoyen le citoyen et dark renaud girard
les journalistes julia de funès est ce
que vous pensez que cette cette
difficulté ce malaise qui s'installe
entre emmanuel macron et mouvementée
gilet jaune c'est encore quelque chose
de factuel ou où c'est plus profond que
s'attaque à une incompréhension c'est
beaucoup plus profond et je pensais je
suis pas dans du macumba chine non plus
parce que j'ai trop de respect pour
cette fonction pour le critiquer comme
ça néanmoins je pense que sa stratégie a
été très mauvaise sur ce discours là
parce qu'il a tenté de rationaliser ce
qui n'est absolument plus rationalisée à
bhl pour les gilet jaune
on sait très bien que l'écologie c'est
pas le souci d'ailleurs si les gilet
jaune avait été aussi très cohérent il
aurait dû être reçues non pas au
ministère de l'écologie avec de rugy mon
ministère des finances il
oui voilà exactement mais on aurait dû
leur répond encore une fois ils n'ont
pas été entendus véritablement et il
oublie je trouve ce philosophe de
formation il oublie sa classe de
philosophie éléments
r je rappelle juste une phrase de marx
suis pas marxiste mais ce n'est pas la
conscience qui détermina vie c'est la
vie qui détermine la conscience ça veut
dire quoi les idées ne viennent jamais
duo elles viennent toujours de nos
conditions d'existence
or là dans son discours c'était vraiment
des idées transcendante belle noble des
grandes causes mais qui ne parle plus
aux gens avant de parler de l'air pur il
faut parler du pain quotidien
alors je me suis fait juste poser la
question pourquoi parce que c'est un
homme excessivement intelligent c'est il
ya une communication parfaite donc c'est
pas ça qu'est ce qui fait qu'à un moment
savry à ce point et je me dis mais
finalement est-ce que ce serait pas un
péché d'orgueil a pas vouloir revenir
sur sa décision il confond un peu le
temps narcissique et non et le temps
historique et sa plus grande victoire me
semble qu'il serait à la hauteur
aujourd'hui d'un renoncement
on pense toujours le renoncement comme
un retour en arrière et je pense que ce
serait une vraie grandeur pour habitude
de maxit d'aigaliers d'accord avec julia
de funès mais pas jérôme sainte-marie
est en désaccord courtois dans la mesure
où je pense qu'effectivement s'il ya
crise et si la crise va est en train de
monter aux extrêmes c'est bien parce que
tout le monde est dans une logique dont
il ne peut pas sortir et pas pour des
raisons psychologiques même qu'on a une
formation de philosophe qui n'est pas
exactement aussi grande que ce qui avait
été évoqué mais bon en tout cas c'est ce
qu' il ya quand même des acteurs alors
les gilets jaunes c'est très particulier
c'est pas très facile de parler
d'ailleurs sur les gilet jaune parce que
c'est vraiment une nébuleuse mais en
tout cas pour le pouvoir il ya une
contrainte qui était double contrainte
qui est très forte
d'une part le président de la république
est réduit à son socle social et
politique du premier tour
grosso modo un quart des français c'est
un quart des français qui l' ue27
or n'importe qui aurait été élu au
second tour y compris benoît hamon par
exemple d'après les sondages
donc en fait il est réduit à son socle
de premier tour il ne peut pas le
désespéré j'ai entendu monsieur girard
je ne sais pas si monsieur gérard à
voter pour monsieur macron c'est pas mon
problème mais en tout cas je sais que ce
qui a fait qu'ils sont dans cette
logique là ne pourrait pas accepter et
donc il est s'affaiblirait encore
davantage en reculant donc il a fait un
choix parce que ça c'est sur la scène
politique intérieure mais il ya beaucoup
plus cette histoire de budget parce que
c'est une question de budget quand même
si vous voulez c'est pas la fin du mois
contre la fin du monde contrairement à
cette formule très facile tout le monde
est dedans et je pense à la fin du mois
la fin du mois pour les budgets la fin
du mois pour le budget
l'état et la fin du mois par rapport à
nos engagements européens
on n'est pas en apesanteur c'est bien
parce qu'on a une logique de respect des
engagements européens pris souvent avant
d'ailleurs monsieur macron y compris par
les socialistes que l'on est contraint
de cette forme d'austérité budgétaire et
que donc si macro reculer maintenant
outre le tort qu'il ferait au reste de
son quinquennat il devrait en plus un
vrai problème par rapport à nos
partenaires européens et cinq ans dans
la vème république 35 ans de reculade en
reculade sur la réforme devaquet qui est
une très bonne réforme recul à la liste
des reculades n'a pas ce trafic sur
l'écotaxe de désocialisation
mais j'ai entendu qu'ils étaient
difficiles si vous voulez comme l'avait
dit d'être présent la république je
pense qu'il est aussi difficile
aujourd'hui de défendre mais vous avez
eu beaucoup de talent pour nous laisser
croire que c'était quelque chose qui
était encore audible
objectivement quand vous dites je remets
ça te maries qu' il n'ya finalement ils
y sont contraintes
il ya eu des choix la réalité
aujourd'hui d'abord c'est que je suis
totalement d'accord avec vous je pense
que le gouvernement et le présent dans
le public et dans le désarroi que
effectivement ils sont il ne veut pas
perdre la face parce que sa stratégie
deux présidents a été d'être en
permanence dans la verticalité et que je
crains qu'il n'ait pas l'intelligence de
pouvoir revenir sur les décisions qu'il
a prises préalablement par narcissisme
je suis totalement d'accord avec vous et
c'est grave parce que la situation du
pays elle est grave quand vous dites que
il n'y a pas de choix il ya les choix
possibles quand on décide de mettre 5
milliards d'euros par an sur en
direction des 1 % des ménages les plus
aisés et prônons la flat tax par exemple
qui font qu'aujourd'hui ils ont un gain
de dix mille euros ça à brac sur les
revenus des gaitas exactement 11 à ça
pourrait permettre de pousser un choix
budgétaires on peut en faire d'autres
et deuxièmement entendez le pour les
gens qu à qui on demande de faire des
efforts aujourd'hui c'est mal perçu
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment qu'il n'y
en a qui sont des privilégiés
et si vous voulez véritablement avoir
une vraie stratégie sur la transition
écologique il faut expliquer comment
vous répartissez les efforts les rendre
jusqu'ici derniers mois juin dernier
oui et on a toujours le champ des
condamnés at il choisi on traite le
président son peuple ou un élément des
directives européennes
mais il a le choix il est responsable de
ce choix là et là il fait pas le choix
de son peuple c'est tout merci beaucoup
moins cher au dessus dit désolé mais
parce que on a encore plein de sujets
passionnants à traiter à commencer par
celui que vous avez évoquées dans votre
billet d'hier dans le figaro c'est à
dire les tensions entre la russie et
l'ukraine
on va venir sur ce qui s'est passé
exactement mais pour vous montrer un
petit peu l'ambiance je vous propose de
regarder ces quelques images ou petro
porochenko qui est le président de
l'ukraine revient sur les tensions avec
la russie
il ne parle pas de cet incident naval
sur lequel on va revenir mais dit il ya
bien d'autres choses
il ya carrément des chars russes qui se
massent à sa frontière et ça ça
n'inquiète regarder ses yeux ce matin
yacouba tchité qui stand qu'il n'a pas
acquis qu'il est chaud au niveau
national 2 0 cela richie a marqué à
bobigny alors va revenir sur le conflit
général mais renault gérard à ce que
vous voulez bien vous approchez de la
carte qui est là pour nous rappeler en
quelques instants
ce qui s'est passé dimanche dernier
pourquoi c'est un pourquoi est un
problème bien il ya une petite flottille
est en fête avec un remorqueur et deux
petits canonnière si vous voulez de
petits bateaux armés qui ont quitté
odessa en pleine ukraine pour aller dans
une eau bien sur les côtés pour que nos
téléspectateurs dans une autre ville
d'ukraine qui est mario paul qui est une
ville qui n'a pas été
prise lorsqu'il ya eu l'offensive des
rebelles pro russes qui ont pris donc
les saisons grisés du dombass donne est
éloquent deux districts du dombass voilà
et le problème c'est que il y a là un
pont le pont de caisse c'est à dire que
les russes se sont saisis de la crimée
en mars 2014 après un référendum a fait
un homme qui n'a pas qui était massif
d'approbation parce que la pollution de
crimée et pro russe mais qui n'a pas été
reconnue par la communauté
internationale
donc la russie a pris la crimée mais
elle ne pouvait la ravitailler que par
la mer puisqu'il avait pas de continuité
territoriale à la russie s'arrête là
fanées et donc ils ont construit un pont
qui était inaugurée en mai dernier par
le président poutine de 19 km sur le
détroit de kertch est simplement un
biais des ukrainiens qui étaient contre
l'existence de ce bond qui ont dit
qu'ils allaient le dynamite et donc les
russes ont décidé de faire des
inspections à tous les bateaux qui
rentreraient dans la mer d'azov en
passant sous sous ce pont notamment pour
rejoindre le port ukrainien 2
mario paul or ce qui s'est passé c'est
que cette petite flottille a voulu
échapper pas aux contrôles
s'estimant chez elle il faut voir que là
le cren reconnaît pas l'annexion de la
crimée a voulu échapper au contrôle de
des garde-côtes russe et donc a été
bousculé un bateau qui était bousculé il
ya eu des tirs mais pas directement pour
tuer c'était des tirs de semonce d'un
bond pour impressionner pour intimider
et les trois bateaux ukrainiens ont été
conduits de force dans un port de caisse
tout ça a commencé
il faut le bien de le voir en mars en
mars 2018
il y à un bateau de pêche qui venait de
crimée et qui a été arraisonné par des
bateaux de guerre ukrainien
c'est à partir de ce moment là comment
représailles si vous voulez que les
russes ont institué ce contrôle sur le
détroit de série chez renault je propose
de rejoindre votre place et pendant que
vous vous installez alors jetez pas qui
se sent suffisamment familier du sujet
pour dire si à son avis il ya un risque
de guerre à partir de cet incident
maxime d'égailler je suis je suis pas un
spécialiste
de cette question est ce qu'il ya un
risque de guerre je note mois qu'il y
avait une désescalade
quand même depuis les accords de mines
que la communauté internationale
aujourd'hui il fait preuve de moins de
fermeté que
il y à une tentative au delà de
l'annexion de la crimée de la part de la
russie de revendiquer les eaux
territoriales et qu'il serait
j'ai à dire de bonne guerre mais la
formule très malheureuse il serait
nécessaire que nous puissions de nouveau
parler d'une seule voix quand je dis
nous c'est notamment l'allemagne et la
france qui ont été à l'origine de
désaccords et j'ai noté une position
ferme de l'allemagne ouvrant la
possibilité de sanctions vis-à-vis de la
russie ça me semble important j'ai pas
noté la même fermeté du côté des
françaises de drian puisque si j'ai bien
compris il veut eu des échanges récents
et la parole était un peu plus faible ce
qui est préoccupant parce que je ne
pense pas qu'on arrive à la guerre par
contre on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui la
russie essaie de profiter de la
faiblesse relative notamment de l'europe
pour consolider ces positions qui sont
des compositions aujourd'hui qui
nécessitent d'être combattue puisque
effectivement ils ont annexé un
territoire qui est la crimée alors on
vous a posé la question sur twitter
selon vous une guerre est elle possible
entre l'ukraine et la russie
vous nous dites oui à 59% c'est un sujet
qui vous intéresse beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de commentaires
il ya macabre nitot qui nous dit on a
bien vu que personne n'a réagi avec
l'annexion de la crimée sous-entendu les
russes peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent
c'est aussi l'avis de monsieur babineau
qui nous dit il n'y aura pas de guerre
l'armée russe est beaucoup trop forte et
fouquet nous dit on ne pourra pas parler
de guerre les russes seront à kiev avant
que les journaux aient eu le temps d'en
rendre compte
renaud girard où il ya un risque de
guerre où on en reste à des mesures
d'intimidation là très clairement en
fait c'est une petite provocation des
ukrainiens qui peuvent ce qu'on vend
pour qu'on n'oublie pas le cas le cas de
l'ukraine et pour qu'on en parle et donc
tenues qu'on en parle au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies moi je ne
pense pas qu'une politique de sanctions
puissent faire changer la stratégie d'un
pays comme la russie qui a quand même
tenu pendant 1000 jours au siège de
leningrad face à l'armée allemande ont
fait pas changer des rues g 500 qui sont
qu'amour déjà et ce sera aussi par
ailleurs je remarque que les sanctions
commerciales pénalise la france puisque
la part de marché de la france en russie
a diminué de 34% alors que la part de
marché de l'allemagne comme par hasard
augmenté de 2%
donc ça c'est la région samax eh bien
voilà
pourquoi il faudrait faire je pense que
je pense que vladimir poutine se rend
compte qu'il a commis une erreur
stratégique en investissant le dombass
la région l'a donc que je montrais à
partir de face les rebelles pro russe
puis l'armée russe qui est intervenu
clandestinement à partir d'août 2014 je
pense que c'est une erreur stratégique
mais je pense qu'il faudrait en fait dit
les c'est-à-dire de 10 rebonds parce
qu'en fait l'obsession de la russie
c'est de garder l'ukraine comme un
glacis voilà et leur obsession c'est que
c'est que l'ukraine ne rentre jamais
dans l'otan il est vrai qu il eu des
promesses qui ont été faites d'ailleurs
à paris par le président achebouche
gorbatchev que jamais le temps ne
s'étendrait vers ces pays de l'est où se
retirer à l'époque en 1990 les forces
russes soviétique et met donc moi je
pense qu'on pourrait faire un deal en
disant bon l'ukraine n'en saura jamais
dans le temps on est bien d'accord mais
vous vous retirez donc vous rendez les
les territoires et notamment la
frontière ukraino-russe aux forces sucre
nn quant à la crimée et bien ça sera un
deal entre les ukrainiens et les russes
dans 20 ans il faut bien voir que les
russes ne rendrons jamais la crimée
crime et ne reviendra jamais l'ukraine
comme le kosovo ne reviendra jamais la
serbie il faut rappeler que le kosovo a
été arrachée à la serbie par une
opération militaire au 6 août n'est pas
de l'otan entre mars et juin merci on va
revoir la carte pour qu'on comprenne
bien tout ce que vous nous avez dit donc
la zone que les russes pourraient rendre
en signe de bonne volonté c'est donc
celle qui se trouve à la frontière
ce bel de la crème voilà qui n'ont
jamais qu'ils ont jamais accepté
d'annexer la zone qui est en pointillé à
l'est de donetsk
julia de funès votre avis sur ce sujet
mon avis il reprend les mots de monsieur
on peut encore dit les comme vous avez
dit donc parler de guerre ça me semble
improbable parce que si on peut dîner ça
veut dire qu'on ait encore des intérêts
des deux côtés et ce ne sont jamais les
intérêts qui déclenche les guerres ce
sont les patients tout dans l'histoire
humaine
ce sont à chaque fois des passions qui
ont déclenché les guerres passion de la
patrie d idéologie religieuse
nationaliste de révolution peu importe
la passion mais ce ne sont jamais pour
le sait n'a jamais été pour le pétrole
pour l'argent pour les matières
premières qu on a déclenché des guerres
donc temps que des intérêts ne se
transforme pas en passion aveugle
à mon avis on est loin de la guerre
encore bon et je passais par là anti mac
qui remercie renault gérard pour son
sens de la pédagogie
nous aussi d'ailleurs jérôme
sainte-marie point de vue purement
française d'hier les comment les
représentations s'organise autour de
cette question de la russie et
accessoirement de l'ukraine en france
est absolument fascinant on a eu ce
témoignage à l'instant sur le plateau de
voir à quel point la gauche ou plus
précisément le parent socialiste adopte
une position résolument pro otan en
toute matière c'est absolument fascinant
de voir que françois hollande est allé
jusqu'à ne pas envoyer délégation
française pour le 9 mai sur la place
rouge pour l'anniversaire de la seconde
guerre mondiale et la victoire que l'on
doit comme d'ailleurs en grande partie
la victoire de 14-18 au sacrifice de
millions de russes
il est très intéressant de voir un
discours optimiste il ya un gros temps
est un bon l'otan il ya il ya
effectivement un grand discours sur les
valeurs qui tombe complètement à côté
d'une part parce que le 's&p' associés
ne s'oppose pas à certaines élections
territoriales ailleurs y compris au
proche orient que par ailleurs en tout
cas pas très vivement que par ailleurs
et bien on ne vous entend pas
par ailleurs il y avait pas que par
ailleurs de tendre l'oreille pour rester
sur la russie que effectivement même la
question ukrainienne que l'on a adopté
un récit sur maidan et sur l'ukraine qui
est assez surprenant
à laquelle il avait eu c'est
l'affrontement entre ukrainien pro russe
et ukrainien pro qui l'entourent que
j'ai été d'ailleurs en 2004 s'est tu
quand j'étais étudiant vous voyez que
j'ai des amis et d'ailleurs nous avons
maintenant une offre qui est d'adapter à
cela avec monsieur glucksmann puisque
l'espace public qui ne voit aucun
problème à adopter le point de vue d'un
gouvernement et d'une majorité dans
lequel il ya des éléments qui ne sont
pas pro nazi en réalité ils sont en asie
c'est à dire qu'effectivement ils
défilent en uniforme de division saas
est restée qui soutient le secteur et
crâniens grands pays la shoah par balles
dire on est quand même dans un univers
assez surréaliste où les mêmes qui ont
un discours sur le valeur et la moselle
est la morale à mauvais mémoire laboral
etc en france en ukraine comme on efface
un espèce de démons totalement fantasmé
sur la russie mais ça je veux pas parler
la russie ménigon des représentations
c'est fascinant ce double standard où
effectivement quand il s'agit de contrer
la russie et l'adopté le prévenu l'otan
alors là on est une transformation
totale du devoir de mémoire et le grand
paris c'est qu'en fait c'est vrai que
dans cette contre-offre ans dans cette
danse est de ceux des dégénérescences si
vous voulez en ukraine au donbass à
partir de juin juillet 2014
effectivement pour mater des rebelles
pro russes et des ukrainiens du don basm
qui était pro russe on a envoyé
notamment des bataillons est certes un
bataillon notamment le baptême d'azov
était composé de deux d'un nazi
ouvertement nostalgique là c'est vrai
qu'il y avait d'ailleurs eu un reportage
là dessus sur le vidéo magazine on
rappellera que le conflit dans le
donbass a fait dix mille morts nous
passons à un autre sujet heureusement
beaucoup moins belliqueux celui de
l'union difficile entre les droites
françaises
lundi soir dernier marion maréchal
pourtant officiellement retiré de la vie
politique animé une soirée débat dans
une brasserie du 9e arrondissement de
paris devant le cercle audace et un
groupe de gens qui est favorable au
rapprochement entre les droites et
marion maréchal a dit mais nous pouvons
voir émerger une nouvelle droite néo
conservatrice qu'elle définit comme un
mouvement qui devra poser des limites
qu'il s'agisse de frontières
territoriales ou de bord
nos exigences et désirs immédiats de
lobby ultra minoritaire et à la cité
l'exemple de la gpa
jérôme sainte marie c'est cette union
des droites ce rapprochement entre les
électeurs du version nationale et ceux
des républicains
est ce que c'est un fantasme comme on a
posé la question en titre de ce sujet
c'est un sujet très délicat sur lequel
vient toutes les forces en présences
butent depuis des années pourquoi parce
que effectivement on sait notamment en
ivan un sondage désormais un peu anciens
de 2015 dans le figaro magazine qui
montrait que sur la question des de
l'immigration de la sécurité sur tout ce
qu'on appelle le régalien
il y avait une convergence totale le
l'ifop avec les occurrences tester donc
en général mais des propositions de ce
qui était à l'époque le front national
et on voyait que les électeurs de ce qui
devait être à l'époque l'ump et bien
adopté totalement presque autant que les
électeurs du front national
ces dispositions là ces propositions
électorales mais qu'inversement il y
avait un hiatus terrible sur l'euro donc
on a effectivement un grand courant
d'opinion aujourd'hui qui va plutôt
grandissant avec un accord sur la
dimension qui était initialement la
pluie diaboliser du discours du front
national est désormais du rassemblement
national mais en même temps il y à une
impossibilité au niveau des doubles au
niveau des appareils bien sûr puisque là
il n'y a aucune
comme on irait si aucune convergence des
appareils dominant notamment la droite
ne veut pas de ce genre de choses et
puis aussi comme une autre divergence
qui est plus fondamental c'est que quand
on passe à la dimension économique et
sociale
là il ya une différence très importante
et que la ligne incarné par milliard
marion maréchal-le pen peut paraître à
beaucoup de gens comme une ligne
finalement assez féconde électoralement
sans porter de jugement de valeur sur le
fond et sur les valeurs
mais c'est mais ça pose un problème
parce que malgré tout pour l'instant
marion maréchal-le pen n'a carne pas du
tout la représentation des catégories
populaires qui font la force électorale
du rassemblement national marine le pen
a réalisé 37 % par les ouvriers 24 parmi
les employés à mon avis cette influence
est encore accrue depuis l'élection
présidentielle va s'accroître encore
avec le mouvement des gilet jaune et je
ne suis pas sûr que ce soit compatible
avec une forme d'offre à la marion
maréchal-le pen droite
et puis autre chose vont compléter ce
que vous disiez on peut ajouter que il
n'y avait ni représentant du
rassemblement national ni représentant
des républicains lors de cette rencontre
on vous a posé la question sur twitter
pensez vous qu'une union des droites est
possible vous êtes 42 % à considérer que
oui ça veut dire que majoritairement
vous êtes assez d'accord avec l'analyse
de jérôme sainte-marie et gêne nous dit
oui l'union des droites est possible à
condition de se rassembler sur un projet
contenant les points les plus important
est de faire abstraction des petits
désaccords
julia de funès votre point de vue sur ce
sujet oui moi aussi je pense que c'est
très possible et pas souhaitable au sens
je ne partage en rien les les points de
vue de l'extrême droite néanmoins est
quelque chose qui m'apparaît comme
ringard et terrible du côté de la droite
traditionnelle c'est quand elle vous
jure les grands responsables de droite
vous jure droit dans les yeux avec
bravoure que jamais ils ne passeront la
frontière avec l'extrême droite et c'est
quelque chose une éthique de conviction
forte
je trouve qu'il ya l'éthique de
conviction bien sûr que je partage
complètement mais à un moment il ya la
responsabilité et ce qu'est ce qu'on
observe dans toute cette europe c'est
quand même que les populismes
l'emportent et là j'ai quand on parlait
de macron jeu musée ya comme une force
qui va macro qui va vers directement
vers l'extrême droite pour les
prochaines élections
une pièce que l'intérêt de la droite ce
n'est pas au contraire de l'exclure de
s'exclure de l'extrême droite en dit en
me disant on ne pactisera pacte brisera
jamais avec le diable mais rentrez dans
l'intérieur de ceux de ce grand magma de
droite pourrait venir bornes et
rationalisé nuancé ses positions
extrêmes
est-ce que la l'exclusion et la
radicalisation l'isoler isolement avec
ce parti là serait pas nuisible en
termes de responsabilité pour la droite
c'est la question
voilà le point de vue de macabres nitot
et maxime d'égailler réagira difficile
de voir la différence entre la ligne
wauquiez et celle de nombreux frontiste
d'abord moi je suis un peu j'étais un
peu gêné par la façon dont vous allez
poser le débat parce que qu'on parle de
marion maréchal-le pen on parle pas de
l'union des droites on parle d'une
conversion des droites parce que
pour moi les à l'extrême droite et cette
conversion là elle n'est pas nouvelle
c'est toute la théorie d'alain de
benoist les trois identité immigration
insécurité et la conviction que il était
possible de convertir la droite aux
positions extrêmes notamment en mettant
à bas l'héritage républicain de la
droite revient pas sur l'héritage
organise 2 qui est qu'à une histoire
quand même dans ce pays de la droite
mais on voit bien que en tout cas c'est
la tentation qui n'est pas nouvelle donc
que d'une parti d'extrême droite
d'arrivée de pouvoir arriver au pouvoir
par par sept par cette façon là là où
moi je suis gêné sais pas si c'est un
fantasme en tout cas moi j'ai une
inquiétude c'est qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui marion maréchal-le pen
profite du vide de la droite et que vous
l'avez dit wauquiez et d'autres
considèrent pour des raisons pas de
valeur mais de stratégies électorales
que le seul moyen de reconquérir le
pouvoir est d'arriver à une convergence
entre les forces électoral du front
national du rassemblement national et
une partie à droite ça me semble
particulièrement préoccupant votre point
de vue renault gérard c'est que si je
devais faire la politique mais c'est pas
mon âge je vais commencer en faire ce
soir et je choisirais plutôt la gauche
que la droite semble assez curieux pour
un journaliste du figaro ce que c'est
quand même beaucoup plus facile de faire
la politique de se faire élire à gauche
parce que ça va sans dire un mot
on a le droit vous êtes soutenus par
l'extrême gauche puis si on n'a pas un
passé extrêmement douteux par exemple
qu'on a été par exemple 36 comme
monsieur monsieur jospin ça passe comme
une lettre à la poste
trotsky faut rappeler ce qu'est trotsky
c'est un staline raté aussi violent il a
créé la guépéou il a fait là il il a
fait la répression des marins de
cronstadt il a bien mérité et où le coup
il a bien mérité trotsky le coup de
piolet du camarade ramon mercader
je maintiens qu'il a bien mérité ce but
de mieux les cowboys devedjian à qui
personne ne met en cause le fait qui
vivra par le glaive perea par le glaive
alors voilà et on a le droit tout à fait
de se faire élire par l'extrême gauche
c'est donc l'extrême gauche par exemple
à participer évidemment à l'élection de
monsieur hollande et des présidents
socialistes qui ont été là avant lui à
revanche lorsqu'on est de droite et
qu'on aurait un soutien de la droite
plus radicale plus extrêmes à quelle
horreur qu elle alors je pense pas
d'ailleurs qu'il faut pas les du maillot
maréchal le pen comme d'extrême droite
parce que pour moi l'extrême droite ce
sont les gens comme déroulède ou comme
le général boulanger c'est ceux qui ne
respectent pas l'ordre républicain
je ne pense pas que madame marion
maréchal le pas le pen elle elle veut
elles respectent pas la république je
pense qu'elles respectent les lois de la
république et que les respecte jusqu'au
bout donc c'est important sur l'extrême
gauche les partis d'extrême gauche en
france par exemple il contestait la
légitimité des institutions qui disait
bourgeoise et qu'il fallait renverser
par la force donc c'est quelque chose il
ya une extrême droite qui a voulu
d'ailleurs le par exemple en février 34
renverser par la force qui considèrent
illégitime d'aider les institutions
républicaines on vous dit qu'à aucun
obstacle morale un rapprochement en tout
cas à la droite de marion machin
brasilia après il ya des choix mal dans
tous les pays si vous voulez aux
etats-unis par exemple vous avez leur
ait pu les partis républicains vous avez
des gens qui vont du centre comme le
sénateur qui viennent de qui vient de
mourir qui avait été candidat
mes héros de la guerre son nom m'échappe
qui avait p maquet voilà qui avait été
jusqu'à jusqu'au tea party du tea party
beaucoup plus au moins aussi à droite
et en plus à droite que le
rassemblement national le parti
conservateur c'est la même chose et
seulement seulement en france on ne
pouvait pas imaginer alors moi je pense
je pense que je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui doit être effectivement
envisagée qui a aucune raison que la
droite refuse pour plaire à la gauche
pour plaire aux journaux de gauche le
soutien de l'ex bad
en revanche on a tout à fait le droit
d'avoir ses opinions alors
personnellement je suis pro européen
évidemment je ne vais pas aller avec le
front national
mais mais mais mais mais je suis je suis
sidéré mais je suis sidéré par le fait
que cette droite française et comme on
dit en anglais mesmerize notizai pas la
gauche qui a ramené à mener vous à votre
bon merci mauvais mais un mot de
conclusion la tude très bref feront
maintenant ou d'un mot je pense que
monsieur girard a raison de rappeler
qu'en politique les mots n'ont de sens
que si on ne donne un sens objectif
qu'effectivement cette invocation de
l'extrême gauche ou de l'extrême droite
devient très fragile
quand il ya reconnaissance des
institutions républicaines et ça aboutit
à des choses un peu absurde comme les
discours de monsieur castaner par
rapport au gilet jaune et aux
comparaisons que le 6 février 34
l'enjeu serait un petit peu en désaccord
et monsieur girard sait que de fait à
l'extrême gauche
je provoque téléspectateur peut le dire
je ne crois pas qu'il y a beaucoup de
formations d'extrême gauche
aujourd'hui qu'ils soient dans autre
chose que dans une logique elle même
électoraliste et defacto républicaine
merci quelques minutes encore pour nous
permettre d'aborder un dernier sujet il
y à une proposition de loi qui passe
demain à l'assemblée nationale et dont
l'objectif est de d'interdire la fessée
je vous en lire l'article principal des
enfants droit à une éducation sans
violence les parents ne peuvent utiliser
de moyens d' humiliations que sont la
violence physique et verbale
les punitions ou les châtiments
corporels ou les souffrances morales
cette proposition parlementaire est
soutenue par plusieurs ministres dont
marlène schiappa parce qu'internet a
chargé de l'égalité hommes femmes
elle l'a dit sur france info le 15
novembre il n'y a pas de petites claques
toute violence a des séquelles
importantes c'est maintenant démontrer
scientifiquement sur les enfants dans
toute leur vie y compris lorsqu'ils sont
à dur en 2018 je ne vois pas qui
pourrait être défendre l' usage de la
fessée et des violences ordinaires
éducative et bien nous avons trouvé
quelqu'un qui défend il s'appelle fabien
di filippo c'est un député les
républicains de la moselle et il l'a dit
jeudi dernier c'était lors d'une réunion
de commission de l'assemblée nationale
puis de l'autorité dans notre société
elle ne passe bien évidemment pas par
les coups mais vous allez bien plus loin
avec ce texte ça a été dit tout à
l'heure quand on met un enfant contre sa
volonté en le contraignant physiquement
au coin est-ce que ça rentre dans le
cadre de cette loi une tape sur la main
quand il a voulu mettre la main sur la
plaque qui était un peu trop chaude
est-ce que c'est grave quand vous dites
que notre société est gangrénée par la
violence je pense qu'il ya bien d'autres
choses
au préalable auquel vous pourriez vous
attaquer de manière plus forte
je pense aux kalachnikovs et aux armes à
feu
question simple renault gérard faut-il
interdire la fessée je pense que madame
je pense que ça c'était c c'est
effrayant c'est un monde orwellien
on voit des députés l'état qui veut
entrer dans la vie de la façon dont les
gens et du chlore enfants je pense
qu'effectivement va une fessée vannes
gers et c'est alors il ya évidemment des
excès qui sont constatés par la dass
très bien et des envieux questions sont
d'ailleurs poursuivies depuis toujours
tout à fait tout à fait enfin je pense
que je pense que l'état déjà beaucoup de
mal à s'occuper de l'instruction
publique qu'il arrive qu'il qualifie
d'ailleurs bizarrement d'éducation
nationale non on devrait rétablir le
titre de ça c'est une autre sujet le
ministère de l'instruction publique mais
que l'éducation et doit être laissée aux
enfants aux parents les et aux parents
et les dividendes et qq qu'une fessée
vannes a jamais n'a jamais fait de mal à
personne que tu en es journées journée
j'en ai reçu lui-même j'étais
figurez-vous dans des collèges anglais
il ya très longtemps où il y avait
encore les châtiments corporels
eh bien oui je me suis fait j'ai reçu
des coups de bâton la course à la voile
âge est ce que j'avais j'avais été pris
par un piot c'est en étudiant plus plus
âgés dans un cimetière avec des copains
en train de fumer des cigarettes à l'âme
en sera pire et bien et bien ça va pas
fait de mal et j'ai préféré cette cette
punition physique gentil de coups de
bâton à aa la dénonciation au à mes
parents avec avec toute la procédure
posés sur le casier judiciaire non voila
voila j'ai reçu des coups de pied au cul
merce jamais fait de mal à personne n'a
pas empêché leur très normale sup
voilà maxime d'égailler écouter d'abord
je rappelle que le parlement a déjà voté
cette loi qui avait été censuré par
conséquent constitutionnel pour des
questions de forme donc il n'y a pas des
choses très nouvelles et j'ajoute aussi
que ça fait 30 ans qu'on saigne des
conventions qu'on parte à qui de toute
façon interdisent ce qu'on appelle des
violences éducatives
son principe sur le printemps la loi d'
interdire ça sur le principe est ce que
la loi doit rentrer dans le domaine du
privé oui parce que quand vous avez une
femme tous les trois jours une femme qui
meurt en raison des coups de son
conjoint on voit bien qu'il est
nécessaire que
l'état la collectivité s'intéresse aussi
aux rapports privés c'est comme si la
fessée à la femme nuits de fou pas du
tout parce que c'est inquiétant
son trait et c'est le monde d'en bas le
japon c'est une question très
intéressante en réalité soit quelle
honte pour ja légitimité à débattre qui
jusqu où est ce que le l'ordre public
doit s'insérer dans les vies donc c'est
ce que vous avez dit d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure en disant que vous considériez
qu'on avait peut-être d'autres choses à
faire que d'aller s'occuper des
relations intrafamiliales
à la question qui est est-ce que c'est
légitime oui après en réalité et je
crois que ça a été évoqué par la
porteuse la proposition de loi l'idée
est d'en faire un axe de sensibilisation
de validation il ya je crois pas de
sanctions prévues dans le projet de loi
est donc moi j'aurais envie de retourner
la question qui aujourd'hui serait pour
qu'on ait un projet de loi demandant à
ce que on autorise
les châtiments corporels personnes donc
il me semble que cette proposition de la
flamme et à sa juste place
mais en tant que tel ça me choque pas
surtout que le parlement a déjà pris
position dessus que l'état règle de
l'instruction publique pas de lait du
pied sur des enfants je donne deux
points de vue des internautes qui nous
regardent c'est pas un sondage selon
vous faut-il interdire la fessée vous
êtes 83% à répondre non et voici
quelques commentaires clos qui nous dit
il faut arrêter de faire des lois sur
tout et n'importe quoi je faut laisser
la liberté aux citoyens
c'est ridicule une loi n'empêchera pas
la fessée au sein du foyer sich l'état
n'a pas entrer dans les foyers et
christian nous dit que les parents se
mesure et ils auront des enfants mesurés
et isométrique
il faut bien distinguer la fessée et la
maltraitance jérôme sainte-marie j'en
reviens à la question faut-il interdire
la fessée par une loi alors moi en tant
que sondeurs toi je trouve ce genre le
débat absolument formidable ça fait
plein d'études possibles
et puis pendant qu'on parle de ça on
parle pas des choses importantes oui
parce que c'est anne aura très peu de
conséquences en fait ce texte là c'est
un merveilleux dérivatifs dans une
période de crise sociale et politique
majeure et effectivement moi je veux
bien en cause et si vous voulez mais ça
me paraît quand même
alors non au seul point que j'aurais et
là dessus je vais faire une alliance
avec monsieur girard sait que quand même
il ya un petit point qui me gêne c'est
pas exactement sur ce sujet là c'est je
crois que c'est le bâton qu'il voit
c'est la trique qu'il est bien non ce
qui m'ennuie un tout petit peu cela
c'est un sentiment que c'est général
dans l'opinion c'est qu'effectivement il
ya le sens les gens ont l'impression
malgré tout de plus en plus et ça c'est
très pernicieux pour l'autorité même de
l'état que il ya de plus en plus de lois
sur des micro comment dirais-je avec des
micros sanctions pour des micro délit et
qu'inversement il ya effectivement des
troubles art au public majeur c'est ce
qu'il ya souligné de manière un peu
caricaturale
le député l'air à l'instant et dans le
reportage et les vents l'impression
qu'ils aient beaucoup de choses qu'on
laisse aller versement rue sanctionne
des petites choses
moi pourquoi je voudrais donner mon
point de vue aussi je trouve qu'il ya un
paradoxe à vouloir interdire la fessée
et à se préparer à autoriser ce qui me
semblait c'est un point de vue personnel
mais j'ai déjà écrit donc je roule je le
partage avec vous ce qui me semble être
une violence bien plus forte qui est de
priver un enfant d'avoir un père et une
mère puisque c'est le projet de la pma
pour les couples de lesbiennes
je viens de finesse parce que finalement
le mot de la fin
super le la question venait à qui on
repasse l'autorité est ce que c'est à
l'état est-ce que c'est au pas on sait
ça au fond et la france a un énorme
problème avec l'autorité
ces post soixante huitard et c'est une
conséquence démocratique aussi parce que
tous libres et égaux on a dérivé vers un
égalitarisme un égalitarisme patentés
qui se retrouve dans chaque sphère
l'état l'entreprise l'école et la
famille à ce problème d'autorité dans
chacune des dans chacune des sphères on
a vu qu'avec la famille des parents
copains ça ne marche pas on a vu à
l'école que le maître copains ça ne
marche pas dans l'entreprise
d'entreprise libérer ou les où il ya
plus de managers tout le monde est
manager ça ne marche pas non plus et le
président normal sans autorité n'a pas
non plus très bien marché donc il s'agit
pas de revenir à l'autoritarisme et aux
coups de bâton bien sûr mais tout
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est
difficile en france à définir c'est
comment on retrouve retourner à une
autorité véritable aux autorités ses
nobles comme terme ça veut dire à hoggar
et du grès que ça veut dire augmenter
les individus et comment on peut arriver
à créer une hiérarchie une verticalité
une autorité sans opprimés une
subordination si vous voulez mais sans
soumission
c'est ça le c'est ça l'enjeu est sur ce
sujet concret je permets de vous poser
l'acte warwi directement puisque j'ai vu
l'année qui est interne à vie convenable
pour vous voyez un et coûtera 30 ans ça
nous coûtera peut-être trente ans de
prison n'est pas 30 ans psychanalyse je
pense d'accord très bien merci pour
cette conclusion merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre c'était passionnant point de
vue reviendra demain avec marie émilie
lombard au même endroit et à la même
heure bonsoir à tous
[Musique]